ja natürlich hat es auch was mit bayer
zu tun wir haben ja alle in der letzten
zeit und sehr verändert und sind sehr
locker geworden und sehr tolerant und
das transgender gehört ja auch dazu aber
es gibt natürlich auch bereiche wo es
überhand nimmt zum beispiel in amerika
der thomas ist eine schwimmerin aber es
eigentlich als mann geboren und hat
schwamm auch als mangel aber dann meinte
sie doch ihren
doch dazu zu stehen dass sie doch
eigentlich eher eine frau ist und bei
wettkämpfen schwimmt sie jetzt
sämtlichen frauen davon ganz klar als
man hat die breitere schultern völlig
anderen muskulatur ist viel kräftiger
und
das ist finde ich gegenüber den
biologischen frauen schon mega ungerecht
weil gerade es gibt viele sportarten da
ist nun mal ein riesenunterschied und
ich bin der meinung da sollte es ein
regel umgehen bei ich finde natürlich
auch das transgender die möglichkeit
haben sollen sport zu treiben aber da
muss man wirklich regelungen finden es
gibt auch sportarten wo es nicht so
wichtig ist oder aber man sagt ihm die
beim boxen es gibt vom welter und
fliegen bis zum schwergewicht
unterschiedliche klassen vielleicht kann
man da solche regelungen einführen aber
das was jetzt so langsam auch in anderen
sportbereichen schule schule macht da
sollte man schnellen riegel vor setzen
weil das ist den frauen gegenüber
ungerecht vor allen dingen den frauen
die früher in der ddr oder auch in china
der männliche hormone gespritzt bekommen
haben die dann verteufelt wurden die
medizinisch körperlich fertig gemacht
wurden durch das doping und jetzt mit
einem mal passiert so etwas
das stimmt etwas absolut nicht ja ich
finde es atemberaubend mit welcher
selbstverständlichkeit frühere männer in
frauen-wettbewerbe eintreten die wissen
doch wie unfair das ist natürlich mal
vor einer der klitschko-brüder oder ins
frauenboxen gehen und sagen jetzt eine
frau ja und dann kämpfte schwergewicht
gegen eine
einen halben meter kleine frau die auch
hat so breit ist wie er das ist doch
völlig unmöglich das muss natürlich von
den sportorganisationen
untersagt werden ganz einfach oder das
muss unbedingt untersagt werden und es
gibt ja auch die möglichkeit zum
beispiel vor vielen jahren die hieß
marien ja ein thailändischer kickboxerin
als ein kickboxer aber in thailand ist
transgender
nicht
wirklich einfach ich erkenne das sofort
aber neue männer fallen drauf rein auf
jeden fall hat die
aber sie hat eben geschminkt und schickt
zurecht gemacht gegen männer gefightet
und hat gewonnen und das ist richtig so
sollte man es machen man kann ja sich
aus lehm und ich finde auch transgender
sollten die möglichkeit haben sport zu
machen aber doch bitte in ihrer
gewichtsklasse
und und ich finde es nicht schön wenn
fußballer oder auch boxer oder egal
welche sportler aufgrund ihrer sexuellen
neigung diskriminiert werden das ist ein
problem ich glaube dass uns noch nicht
gelungen ist bei diesem thema wenn es um
gesellschaftliche toleranz und so geht
ist mal zu differenzieren zwischen
respekt vor der identität wie sich ein
mensch fühlt wie er sein privatleben
führen will oder wie er seine identität
geschlechtlich sieht und andererseits
trotzdem ein paar biologischen fakten
die eine rolle spielen weshalb es eben
verschiedene die verschiedenen
sportarten für männer und frauen
getrennt gibt oder auch verschiedene
andere dinge für männer und frauen
getrennt angeboten werden dass wir das
trennen von der frage nicht das eine ist
besser oder schlechter oder geschlechter
irgendwie anders aufwerten oder abwerten
oder sagen männer oder frauen können
irgendwas nicht aber trotzdem die
sachlichkeit zu haben es gibt
biologische tatsachen die eine
auswirkung haben die auch zählen in
bestimmten bereichen nicht im sinne von
hör- oder schlechter wert ich aber dass
man zu trennen und ich glaube das
gelingt noch nicht und wenn sie es sonst
so viel heißt von otis 1
fakten sehen dann glaube ich brauchen
wir darüber noch mal eine debatte wie
geht man damit klug um mit dem respekt
vor unterschiedlichen gefühlen und
identitäten einerseits und den
biologischen fakten andererseits stehen
dennoch ziemlich am anfang also das
glaube ich wirklich noch einiges zu tun
auch mit der selbstverständlichkeit des
umgangs denn gerade wenn man jetzt eben
anfängt zum beispiel wurde ich ja von
der bildzeitung mal aufgefordert ein
interview zu führen weil jetzt das
buchstabieren nicht mehr mit a wie anton
und baby berta und so weil das ja
irgendwie
geschlechterspezifisch ist sondern man
sollte jetzt städtenamen dafür nehmen
denn es ist ein völlig falsches
selbstverständliches wie man eben mit
trends kindern umgehe den ist das nicht
wichtig sie wollen respektiert werden
und sie wollen
gleichberechtigt sein und sie wollen
gleich voraussetzungen namen aber
natürlich nur so hieß auch geht und ich
muss mal dort war eine frage stellen wie
reagieren die zuschauer auf so
wettbewerber pfeifen die dann wenn der
wenn der frühere man openoffice kraft
wird er dann stetig daran aber ich habe
eine lösung mit dabei vielleicht könnte
man ja einfach dann wenn es dann mehr
werden transgender olympische spiele
macht ist es wo genau dann für die
gruppe aber da wäre dann auch das
problem wieder wenn ein mann zu einer
frau wird ist es ja auch wieder anders
als wenn eine frau zu einem mann wird
auch da hätten wir wieder die
gewichtsunterschiede aber erst schröder
wie sind sie das denn letztlich dieser
fall eigentlich ein komplett das
leistungsprinzip außer kraft
es gibt gewisse punkte wo es klemmt zu
schweigen das ist jetzt sozusagen das
hat mir meine frau hatte der sendung
auch gerade bei meiner davon wir waren
ja letzte woche gemeinsam auf novomind
top veranstaltung war eine super
veranstaltung ging wenn männer und
frauen männer und frauen aber natürlich
sagen kann auch eine gewisse dynamik
entstehen deshalb wenn viele männer
zusammen sind im fußball sondern so eine
gruppendynamik andersrum bei frauen kann
es genauso passieren und manchmal es
dann auch einfach besser man sagt wenn
man davon keine ahnung hat wie in der
politik soll es ja auch sein sollten
auch in der lage sein zu sagen ich habe
keine ahnung oder
mich zu diesem thema am besten
[Gelächter]
beispiel mit dem schwimmen ist jetzt ein
beispiel was wird sich ja in vielen
disziplinen noch
was könnte denn eine möglichkeit seien
einfach die leute in den klassen zu
lassen ist guter vorschlag was du
gemacht hast also wenn es wirklich genug
menschen wirbel auf die das zutrifft
dann könnte man natürlich eigenständige
wettbewerbe austragen aber ich glaube
dass es noch schwierig im moment stehen
insbesondere die weiblichen
sportlerinnen da vor einer schwierigen
entscheidung nämlich ob sie boykottieren
oder sich in einem unfairen wettbewerb
gegeben die müssen sie dramatisch und es
können so finde ich nicht sein wie das
im moment lang soll biologische männer
below dann vorteile haben und am ende
der leistungsgedanke des sports nicht
mehr funktioniert dass sie vom gleichen
körperlichen voraussetzungen ausgehen
die damit ein anderer frauen sollten
nicht die situation gebracht werden dass
sie boykottieren müssen das ist aufgabe
das ist auch irgendwie das zu klären
aber es gibt ja auch sportarten die die
man ruhig machen kann zum beispiel der
reitsport oder schießen also es gibt
einige sportarten ja doch die nicht von
der muskelkraft sondern eher von
geschicklichkeit oder konzentration
abhängig sind
ja und insofern sollte man sich
vielleicht erst wein als transgender auf
diese sportarten